Бориса Джонсон якого українці охрестили
Борисом джонсонюком за його допомогу
Україні від сьогодні вже більше не
Прем'єр Великобританії у своїй
прощальній промові він назвав за Ісусу
героїчними
двері незабаром увійде нова
прем'єр-міністр яка що познайомитися з
фантастичною групою державних діячів це
люди які організували швидке постачання
озброєння героїчні українські армії це
те що могло допомогти змінити курс
найбільшої за 80 років війни в Європі
Я знаю що ліс трас і цей розумний
консервативний уряд зробить усе щоб
допомогти людям подолати цю кризу Ця
країна подолає її і ми переможемо і Якщо
Путін думає що він може перемогти
шантажем та булінгу британців то він
глибоко помиляється
[музика]
Бориса Джонсон у променях сонця
залишають Даунінг Street 10
А тим часом всесвітньо відомий мешканець
прем'єрської резиденції кіт Ларі вже
вийшов на ґанок зустрічати нову
господиню ліс трас ще під час
передвиборчої кампанії за посаду лідера
консерваторів Вона обіцяла що стане
найбільшим другом України на слідуючі
Бориса Джонсона і буде повністю віддано
Тому що Путін зазнав поразки в Україні у
багатьох своїх промовах щодо війни Росії
в Україні ліс раз вживає саме цю фразу
щоб Україна перемогла
Ukraine Україна переможе лізе траса 47
років вона стала третьою прем'єркою в
історії Великобританії її називають
Залізною леді 2:0 натякаючи На її
намагання наслідувати Маргарет Тетчер
ікону британських консерваторів сама ж
ліса трас відхрещується від цих
порівнянь хоча й захоплюється Маргарет
Тетчер та її політикою менше податків із
соцвиплат натомість більше
підприємницької свободи та вільної
торгівлі таких поглядів дотримуються ліс
трас під час своєї урядової кар'єри вона
була і міністркою довкілля і міністркою
юстиції і міністр рекою зовнішньої
торгівлі а рік тому стала головною
дипломаткою Великобританії як міністрка
закордонних справ саме вона зокрема
контролювала запровадження санкції проти
оточення російського президента
Володимира Путіна а також працювала
разом із союзниками щоб надати Україні
більше зброї та гуманітарної допомоги
Ми повинні переконатися що український
народ має зброю необхідну для захисту
Великобританія була першою європейською
країною яка надіслала зброю в Україну а
Чехія була першою країною яка надіслала
в Україну танки
разом ми навчаємо українських бійців
завдяки Британській військові
тренувальній команді Ми також обговорили
важливість відбудови України та плану
Маршала який підтримує вільний світ щоб
відбудувати цю життєздатну країну
Ми повинні бути готові до довготривалої
підтримки України тому що ми віддані
захисту свободи та демократії зараз не
час заспокоюватися не повинно бути
розмов про припинення вогню чи
заспокоєння Путіна нам потрібно
переконатися що Україна переможе і що
Росія відійде і що ми більше ніколи не
побачимо такої російської агресії
ще в липні президент України Володимир
Зеленський висловлював занепокоєння що
наступних Джонсона може зменшити
підтримку України ниніша Зеленський
більш оптимістичний розраховує на щиру
співпрацю вже чекаю коли можна буде
продовжити нашу співпрацю співпрацю
збори саму його новому статусі і не менш
чекає початку співпраці з новим
прем'єр-міністром Великої Британії пані
лійтрас ми в Україні добре її знаємо
Вона завжди була на світлій стороні
європейській політики Я вірю що разом ми
зможемо зробити ще дуже дуже багато для
захисту наших народів і для провалу усіх
російських деструктивних зусиль головне
зберігати нашу єдність А це обов'язково
буде
у Москві ж протягом останніх місяців
дуже зневажливо говорили про ліс трас
Міністерство закордонних справ Росії
відкрито глузувало з неї через
географічні помилки найбільше напруженим
був візит раз до Москви у лютому за два
тижні до початку війни Росії проти
України очільник російського МЗС Сергій
Лавров назвав їхню розмову діалогом між
глухим і німим нині зазначили у Кремлі
Вони теж не можуть сподіватися на щось
позитивне
у найближчій перспективі ми не очікуємо
якихось змін не хотілося б казати що ці
зміни можуть статися на гірше адже ще
гірше уявити собі складно але цього
виключати не можна
експерти з прогнозують що нова примірка
не буде послаблювати тиск на Кремль і
продовжуватиме підтримувати Україну
попри енергетичну кризу в Європі
я б очікував продовження політики
жорсткості щодо вторгнення Росії в
Україну Я не бачу щоб ця позиція
змінилася хоча буде дуже цікаво
спостерігати як розвиватиметься
громадська думка коли витрати на війну
почнуть впливати на гаманці людей Я
очікую що люди і надалі будуть
солідарними з Україною але це може
призвести до цікавого компромісу для
уряду
жодних змін щодо України не буде цілком
очевидно що в національних інтересах
Британії переконатися що ми намагаємося
тримати Росію страху трас мабуть навіть
більше жорстка ніж Джонсон щодо Китаю
тому ми можемо побачити деяку різницю в
тональності але в іншому різниці у
зовнішній політиці не дуже велика
питання для ТРАНС полягатиме в тому чи
зможе вона продовжувати цей конфлікт з
ЄС через Північний Ірландію та при цьому
зберегти дружбу так звані особливі
відносини з США
зрештою експерти переконані що позиція
траси щодо Росії та її повномасштабного
вторгнення в Україну буде й надалі без
компромісною навіть більш категоричною
ніж у її колишнього боса Бориса Джонсона
Володимир Путін не просто націлився на
Україну у своїх жахливій гібридній війні
він намагається змусити нас платити
вигук використовуючи голод і російською
енергією як зброю він робить ставку на
те що вільний світ втомиться від його
агресії Але ми не втомилися і ми ніколи
не зможемо втомитися захищаючи свободу
та демократію і ми покажемо це роблячи
Все можливо щоб Україна перемогла
Росію потрібно притягнути до
відповідальності за цю жахливу війну
розв’язану в Україні Я хочу чітко
пояснити що ми сповнені рішучості надати
Україні необхідну підтримку в
довгостроковій перспективі якби довго не
тривала ця війна тому що це життєво
Важливо не лише для української свободи
та демократії але й для всієї нашої
свободи та демократії щоб Україна
перемогла українці ж кажуть що
сумуватимуть за джонсоном і покладають
Надії на трас та її щиро підтримку
со сльозами на глазах Я це говорю От але
вона
по відношенню до України Я не очікую від
неї якихось
негативних
дій рішень і вона надійний підтримує
Україну я до неї позитивно дуже
відношусь Я дуже сподіваюся що вона буде
все ж таки продовжувати політику Бориса
Джонсона і дуже сподіваємося
що ви її політика від Джонсона щодо
України нічим не відрізняється А це для
нас великий плюс
6 років тому ліс траса несподівано для
багатьох підтримувала членство
Великобританії у Європейському Союзі
тоді вона називала брекзіт потрійною
трагедією більше правил більше форм і
більше затримок під час торгівлі з ЄС
але потім кардинально змінила свої
погляди і підтримала жорсткий курс
Джонсона на брекзіт українці
сподіваються що таких різких розворотів
щодо підтримки України у ліс раз не буде